[Music]
75 years and five days ago it's a
wonderful life premiered on the big
screen just in time for christmas the
film would earn five oscar nominations
but surprisingly wasn't considered a
commercial success yet over the decades
with a big boost from television it's a
wonderful life would grow into a
timeless classic one that still
resonates during this wonderful time of
year
a movie only stands the test of time by
capturing the hearts of nearly any
audience even a clear-eyed movie critic
like david edelstein
i was re-watching this film last night
i was kind of laughing at it and kind of
rolling my eyes
and then all of a sudden i noticed my
eyes were wet
and then i noticed that tears were
coming down my face i was like what what
has happened
what is happening to me
the same thing that's been happening for
the last 75 years to so many watching
jimmy stewart hey nick nick isn't that
mr goddard
in the frank capra classic it's a
wonderful life
i think the combination of capra's
camera of jimmy stewart's elation of how
deep and dark it has gotten and then the
joy at the end who could resist that
it's magical
for the uninitiated the film takes place
in the fictional small town of bedford
falls
following the life of george bailey who
gives up his own dreams to help others
even as a child he has big dreams he
wants to build cities he wants to become
a master of the universe i want to do
something big and something important
and again and again we will see george
forest doctor let's get this thing
straight i'm leaving i'm leaving right
now i'm going to school this is my last
chance following his better instincts
but
against his will
to put others before him right mary i
know what i'm gonna do tomorrow and the
next day and next year and a year after
that i'm shaking the dust of this crummy
little town off my feet and i'm gonna
see the world
italy greece the park this crummy little
town distraught one christmas eve bayley
questions whether his life has mattered
at all that's when a guardian angel
steps in you just don't know all that
you've done if it hadn't been for you
yeah if it hadn't been for me
everybody'd be a lot better off it's a
very american story what is success
how do you define it and if you don't
become rich and famous does that mean
you're nothing or nobody film historian
janine basinger is the author of the
definitive book on it's a wonderful life
this is fantastic i love this and you
see the meticulous
planning and the keeper of director
frank capra's archives was there
anything that stood out that surprised
you when it came to the movie and frank
capra a lot of things surprised me the
main surprise i think is that it was
never intended to be a christmas movie
because he was always aware that this
movie has a real
downer section and it just didn't feel
like a christmas movie in that regard
think about that now exactly it's on
every christmas exactly it was turned
into a christmas movie of course by
television was frank aware of what it
became frank was more than aware of what
it became because as he once said to me
i got a letter from somebody who saw it
on tv
i sat down in a chair to write an answer
to that letter it's been 20 years now
janine and i'm still in that chair
writing letters and he said it was
exactly that
[Music]
the film was shot in los angeles and
capra never revealed the inspiration for
bedford falls
but some believe signs point to seneca
falls new york which has laid claim to
the distinction
there you'll find the it's a wonderful
life museum
and for almost two decades seneca falls
has transformed itself into bedford
falls hosting an annual festival for the
faithful
earlier this month surviving actors of
the movie gathered there
[Music]
including the bayley kids do you have
memories of that set of making this
movie
oh yeah it was the first time i'd ever
seen snow it wasn't real right you know
i thought it was pretty cool
carolyn grimes was just six when she
played zuzia the youngest daughter of
george and mary bailey and delivers one
of the film's unforgettable lines
[Music]
what is it like when you meet these
different fans oh my gosh their face
lights up i mean it's like i'm some kind
of an angel from heaven yeah
always the little girl they see when
they see me so you know she was beloved
and her name is named after you
that just shows in their faces and in
their hearts i had always heard the
reference about when a bell rings and
angel gets its wings right
but that's all i knew about it last year
ashley burton watched the film for her
millennial movie monday youtube series
and see if they stood the test of time
reacting in real time i wish i had a
million dollars
hot dog
what why not right here ah detention
before giving her review yes sir kiss
her from a millennial standpoint of
course it's in black and white and i was
like oh lord this is
we throwing it way back but for the most
part it's a great story about family
that even on the days where you feel
like you maybe don't matter or you
didn't make any big decisions
your life adds up and means something
each man's life touches so many other
lives
thesis statement to david edelstein the
redemption in the last 40 minutes isn't
just for george bailey have returns
please it's also for the movie please
god let me know and on the word god the
snow begins it's not his sadness that
makes you cry it's his joy jenny tommy
and who could resist this
[Applause]
and the last line of the film the last
spoken line is attaboy clarence who has
gotten his wings
and all is right
in the world
and the world on high
a feeling of hope that all can be right
in the world bringing us back year after
year
i think really the last part is what
assures this film a place in the history
of not just christmas movies but
american movies
and why people
75 years from now may still be watching
it it's why people see this film again
and again in
in dark times and in bright times
[Music]
[Music]